Tom Curren Patriots insider NBC Sports
he joins us from the NFL owners meetings
in Phoenix how did this go over when the
news first hit Tom even though we all
kind of expected that there was going
going to be a decision one way or the
other that it dropped Sunday evening at
the owners meetings in mid-march I think
still caught everybody flat-footed and I
kind of wonder about the timing today as
I start to reflect on it given the other
news story that the Patriots have
swirling around them as to whether or
not this is a little bit of a wag the
dog type situation where they said come
on can you please if you're going to
quit quit now today
[Laughter]
well you're used to conspiracy theories
up there so just throw another one on
the fire is this more due to health or
is it maybe a business decision it is
primarily health and the fact that his
body gets beat to hell and over the
course of the season rolling out of bed
after what he articulated during Super
Bowl 50 collision car crashes and then
on Wednesday them saying okay trying to
practice Thursday okay time to practice
Sunday okay 50 more car crashes for you
it got to him now the business stuff did
enter into it Dan though in the notion
that I'm doing this for half of what
Sammy Watkins makes and I know I'm a
better player no disrespect Sammy or any
other wide receiver who's making that
much more with Jimmy Garoppolo making
three times I know it's a different
position but he began probably in 2016
to say well that contract I signed in
2012 was great then now it's horrible
but do you is there any chance that this
is sort of a temporary retirement for
him or do you think he's done done once
we get to mid-august what is Rob
Gronkowski doing he's starting to get
the itch he's starting to get the itch
he's on some movie set somewhere doing
his 58 take
some poor word wine and he's to say what
am I doing here and he's saying you know
what I'm not gonna but I'm not gonna go
back I'm not gonna go back and then
maybe in September he starts in October
it gets harder and then maybe he's back
that's my feeling I don't think it's
permanent
I don't I would say it's there's a
chance that it's not permanent I know
from the folks that I've talked to close
to him that he's relieved that he feels
great about the decision that he's in a
great place mentally which was not in
during the season at all last year he
had a very hard season mentally he's in
a great spot right now but I also think
that what Willie McGinest broached a few
weeks ago about I wouldn't be surprised
if Gronk retired then came back deep in
the season I still think that
possibility definitely exists all right
so how's that changed the Patriots draft
strategy it shouldn't change it at all
they've not done a great job surrounding
the Patriots tight end situation or
Brady sided situation with anyone and a
lot of good players have come out in the
last couple of years hayden hurst david
yoku george Kittles a number of them hmm
so the Patriots need to grab the tight
end there's good tried ends in the grass
they need to make a move there they also
need to make a move of wide receiver
because you have a 42 year old
quarterback with really one player of
note in the past catching realm and
that's Julian Edelman and he's a 30 to
33 year old slot outside hybrid what's
your best drunk story on or off the
field oh boy I think that off the field
okay Justin was the last the last time I
saw him was the Super Bowl I'm standing
there I didn't know that he had made an
announcement that he wasn't making an
announcement that night so I'm kind of
working at his his locker which was next
to a showers you never want that but
whatever so I'm standing there and he's
in this area that's between the the
actual showers in the locker room
ten sinks and everything and he's got
his shoulder pads on his jersey still on
but he's just wearing his jock I'm kind
of just marking and you know glanced
over and he like goes look at this
starts pointing at his thigh like whoa
I'm like what am I looking at he goes
look I'm swollen it is swollen up to
about twice what it should have been and
like wow that's bad you touch it I like
poke at it then go wow that's awful the
second half early so but how Bad's that
gonna be is that the worst you ever had
no but at least I don't have to play
tomorrow so then we had a conversation
about that kind of an injury at how
often he suffered it that's the kind of
thing that you know getting hit by a
human missile who's 220 pounds going you
know that fast is gonna create that kind
of havoc in your body we make this
smooth segue to Robert Kraft oh he said
he was sorry
what's he sorry for great question and
that's why in talking to people I said
you know that's gonna be the hard thing
about apologizing when are you sorry for
yeah he didn't do any illegal I think
what he's sorry for is I know what he's
explaining he sorry for is that a
decision to have a tryst and a strip
mall massage power is not in lockstep
with the person that he has purported
with the image that he is put out there
so that's what he's sorry for and as a
result because of the legal issues it's
come to light and he's sorry that that
is out there people are digesting the
optics of him doing that so I think
that's what he's sorry for talking to
Tom Curren the Patriots insider NBC
Sports Boston joining us from the NFL
owners meetings in Phoenix I'm curious
if the Patriots draft a quarterback if
they're going to look at Josh Rosen and
maybe trade for Josh Rosen or are they
status quo with the quarterbacking
position and backup
it's not a great quarterback class this
year with Brady and Brian Hoyer you
certainly have the oldest quarterback
backup pairing in NFL history I would
think probably close to 79 years old
between them so it wouldn't be a
horrible idea to draft somebody and the
Patriots aren't a top of the draft
quarterback group anyway they'll I'm
Jimmy Garoppolo in a second obviously if
I'm Brady later they drafted Ryan
Mallett so I would think that they're
going to try and target somebody in this
draft in round two through five I don't
think that they're gonna make a deal at
the spot what they do have to do is get
Brady redone because a twenty seven
million dollar cap hit so get him redone
but that it has to be taken care of too
which will give us more information as
to what they're gonna do with the
position whether it be this year or next
year when it's a much better quarterback
new class coming out mm-hmm I have fun
out there Tom good to talk to you as
always thank you a great week that's Tom
Curren Patriots insider NBC Sports
Boston always one of our favorites there
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]